euh donc Jean-Pierre originaire de
laorine a 70 ans et depuis près de 20
ans il se bat contre un cancer des
poumons Jean-Pierre mais il y a quelques
mois Jean-Pierre a une mauvaise surprise
en se rendant à la pharmacie son
médicament n'est plus remboursé en
totalité par la Sécurité Sociale et il
doit sortir une somme folle pour se le
procurer plus de 600 € regardz cette
affaire et il sera avec nous dans un
instant tien ça tu vas le dire ça
Jean-Pierre sera avec nous alle à tout
de suite c'est
parti depuis 18 ans Jean-Pierre
inseptuagénère qui vit en laorine est
atteint dans cancer du poubon et l'homme
sous traitement depuis une dizaine
d'années a récemment découvert que son
médicament n'était plus remboursé
entièrement par la Sécurité Sociale
faute de moyen le retraité qui ne peut
se tourner vers d'autres traitements
après une lourde décision arrêter de se
soigner je me suis battu contre une
maladie maintenant je dois me battre
pour me soigner atteint d'un cancer du
poumon Jean-Pierre qui ne peut plus
payer son traitement et qui arrête de se
soigner témoigne ce soir dans
tespmp merci Jean-Pierre merci merci
d'être là vous êtes donc retraité merci
d'être avec nous vous avez 70 ans il y a
quelques années o diagnostique un cancer
euh et cecer c'est un cancer des poumons
c'est ça c'est ça il il a été pris à
temps euh
j'ai euh commencé à avoir un cancer des
poumons en
2006 alors vous faites donc ensuite j'ai
fait de la
chimiothérapie après je me suis fait
opérer euh du poumon gauche en grande
partie ça s'est bien passé j'ai refait
de la
chimio 2 ans après c'est reparti dans le
poumon droit donc on a dit on va faire
un traitement par cachet un cachet qui
s'appelle ira c'est ça ira 250 mg oui
voilà c'est un c'est un médicament
fabriqué par le laboratoire
astraénenecaine connait bien donc depuis
j'ai toujours pris ce médicament que
j'ai très bien supporté pas de
problème les nodules tout ça sont restés
ce sont stabilisé donc je prends
toujours ce cachet là alors arrivé si
vous voulez oui je peux
m'expliquer le 1er avril un 1er avril
c'est pas un poisson mais tant pis je
vais à la pharmacie la pharmacienne me
voilà oui bon c'est bien je vous le
commande puisqu'il faut toujours le
commander pour pouvoir l'avoir
puis quand ça passe dans l'ordinateur
elle me dit moi je veux bien que vous le
preniez mais il faut payer 635 € comment
madame oui c'est pu rembourser dans sa
totalité voilà donc je peux vous
commander générique ouais d'accord j'ai
essayé une sorte de générique j'ai pris
générique pas de
chance j'ai pas supporté le générique
mux de tête Mosé vomissement saignement
de nez je tenais plus de bout plus rien
j'en ai essayé un deuxième sorte deuxème
laboratoire
myan
impossible donc que faire j'ai c'est
comme ça j'arrête je prends plus de
médicament voilà donc je suis retourné
voir mon pneumologue qui m'a encore dit
là j'ai eu encore une ordonnance et pour
un autre un autre laboratoire un
générique qui se rapproche le plus
possible dirais ça je fais plusieurs
pharmacies jeai fait à bvet je suis chez
mon ami j'en ai fait chez moi
Lorine pas de médicament introuvable
rupture de stock il y en a
pas donc depuis j'ai écris au député
envoyé un mail il a envoyé un une lettre
à Aurélien Rousseau le ministre la santé
le ministre de la Santé et toujours
aucune
réponse donc voilà et du jour au
lendemain on me dit bah oui ensuite mon
médecin à a fait une lettre à la
SCU à la sécurité sociale
euh bah pour demander à ce que j'ai le
bon médicament aujourd'hui vous faites
comment Jean-Pierre aujourd'hui je
prends plus rien non depuis combien de
temps depuis combien de temps depuis
combien de temps bah j'avais une boîte
d'avance pour le mois d'avril donc ça
fait pour dire depuis le mois de mai non
mais juin juillet ou
septembreobre novembre ça va faire 6
mois pas possible ça Jean-Pierre si
c'est possible non mais vous pouvez pas
faire ça il faut faut qu'on trouve une
solution c'est pas possible comment
trouver la solution la réponse de la SQ
a été claire euh je l'ai
là la réponse de la CQ a été bon ce
médicament est placé sous tarif
forfaitaire de tarif de remboursement
unique voilà voilà pour IR ça ce tarif
été fixé à
645,65 € par le comité économique des
produits enfin voilà reste à charge
environ 635
€ alors voilà je vous invite alors je
vous invite à prendre contact avec le
médecin
prescripteur voilà c'est
insupportableors c'est ça c'est ça moi
qui c'est ça qui me rend fou dans ce
pays parce que moi je veux bien aider
tout le monde il y a pas de problème
mais Jean-Pierre vous avez travaillé
dans votre vie vous avez travailléav vie
vous avez travaillé toute votre vie
votre vie toute votre vie vous avez
cotiser toute votre vie vous avez été là
quand vous avez de rien demandé à
personne là vous avez besoin de la
France il faut que les politiques voit
ça vous avez besoin de la France vous
avez besoin qu'on vous aide pour un
médicament à 600 € et on vous dit non et
600 € c'est non vous avez une retraite
vous pouvez pas vous permettre de mettre
600 € je suppose et voilà où on en est
voilà où on en est voilà la France la
France elle en est là aujourd'hui on a
un monsieur qui vient qui a un cancer du
poumon il peut pas se soigner il peut
pas acheter un médicament à 600 € on lui
on l'abandonne on l'abandonne on lui dit
bah c'est pas grave tu as travaillé tu
as cotisé crève et d'un autre côté on va
m'expliquer qu'il y a des gens qui
foutent rien du tout et eux on va leur
dire on va te soigner de A à Z ça c'est
pas possible je peux pas entendre ça moi
pas possible il fait quoi il fait quoi
il fait quoi il attend de mourir il fait
quoi le le pire cyil c'est que l'État
taxe à mort les cigarettes donc je fait
un maximum de blé sur les cigarettes
mais après ne rembourse pas ceux qui
sont victimes des cigarettes donc c'est
c'est incroyable je n'ai il a pasé le
cancer du pummon ça n'a pas diagnostiqué
cancer du poumon attention voilà par je
ne fumais pas ça
fait j'ai fait comme tous les gamins
j'ai fumé étant jeune 20 ans et puis
après terminé c'est pas le problème vous
avez travaillé toute votre vie je vois
pas pourquoi en fin en je vois pas
pourquoi à la fin de votre vie comme ça
en retraite vous êtes malade il vous
arrive un pépin je vois pas pourquoi on
vous dirait ce médicament à 600 € on
vous le donne pas à vous et on va
rembourser des gens à qui on va don
c'est très bien de rembourser les gens
il y a pas de problème mais avant de
rembourser les gens faut vous aider vous
c'est ça c'est ça qui tourne parond on
veut on veut on veut mettre les gens
ouais bah on va le mettre là et on va le
garder en santé on va le faire vivre et
cetera et cetera lui il a rien fait moi
je vous dis même quelque chose on peut
pas créer une cagnotte pour
mais je non non je fais pas l'amendicité
moi ce que
jeité là il faut que vous prenez votre
médicament mais peut-être que j'en
aurais plus besoin du traitement c'est
un risque mais
bon c'est comme ça moi ce que je veux
c'est être retenu le médecin il peut pas
savoir il peut pas je fais des examens
je fais des
T pour le moment c'est stable qu'est-ce
que disent les examens que c'est stable
pour le moment c'est stabilisé il y a
pas beaucoup de
ça ne progresse pas beaucoup pour ASI
dire
c'est mais voilà moi ce que je veux
c'est être reconnu c'est pas normal de
que du jour au lendemain sans me
prévenir sans rien me dire on dit paf
c'est fini c'est symptomatique il
demande rien la plupart des gens qui
sont dans le malheur ils demande rien là
on lui propose une cagnote il dit non
j'en veux pas la plart des gens c'est
mais pourquoi vous êtes pourquoi vous
êtes pourquoi vous bénéficiez pas de la
la l l'ffection de longue duréeou mais j
suis j suis en LD 100 % d'accord pr
charge% sur ce médicament c'est 60 %
seulement c'est 100 % donc il me
rembours ils l'ont bien marqué le
médicament il coûte à peu près 1300 €
PRS euh voilà voilà et donc là
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous
voulez vous allez faire quoi Jean-Pierre
et là alors il m'ont demandé en plus à
CQ vous pouvez éventuellement solliciter
le laboratoire pour une aide à titre
exceptionnel
alorsl incroyable alors mon mon mon mon
mon père qui est médecin dit que votre
votre médicament il est important mais
c'est vrai que voilà on peut on peut
peut-être on peut on peut s'en passer
c'est ce qu'il dit aussi voilà il dit
que il peut parfois ne servir à rien il
dit que voilà il faut il faut il faut il
faut vous vérifier à chaque fois vous
dites que là pour l'instant c'est assez
stable mais voilà il ce médicament voilà
c'est c'est c'est pas voilà il dit que
il peut servir à rien parfois c'est ce
que vous disiez il y a un instant disait
que voilà médicament peut-être que vous
nen avez plus besoin mais quand il en a
besoin sauf c'est vrai c'est vrai ce que
dit votre papa sauf que quand il en a a
besoin est-ce qu'il a les 600 € à l'cher
ben voilà c'est ça mais moi moi c'est ça
le truc c'est que c'est inadmissible
qu'il est pas de quoi payer son
médicament alors comme tu as dit il y a
des gars je suis désolé qui qui c'est
c'est chiant à dire et on veut pas et on
en veut pas à ceux qui qui profitent et
qui pleurent du système tant mieux pour
eux s'ils ont les choses mais il faut
que ce monsieurl il ait les choses si on
donne à des gens c'est l'égalité il faut
donner aussi à tout le monde surtout
qu'il a travaillé toute sa ville
travailler oui dans la lettre que
j'avais écrit j'ai bien marqué je veux
bien que la sécu fasse des économies
mais il ne faut pas confondre un
dolipran oui pour un rhume oui qu'on
peut demander une pièce d' 1 € ou je ne
sais pas combien
avec de la chimiothérapie bien sûr on
peut pas confondre mais g làdus j'ai
jamais rép monsieur la situation elle
est elle est non seulement inadmissible
mais elle est injustifiable je ne
comprends pas puisque dans le Code de
Santé publique c'est clair quand vous
avez un médicament qui vous convient et
que on vous propose d'utiliser le
générique vous devz le faire mais vous
vous avez essayé les génériques ne vous
conviennent pas donc on doit vous
redonner le médic trème générique
laboratoire pourquoi il vous t alors
uniquement celui-là introuvable mais
mais donc pourquoi c'est incroyable la
SCU vous répond ça mais la SCU n'a pas à
répondre ça là là il faut que vous
monsieur moi je vous le dis faut que
vous attaquiez la SCU vous avez raison
de faire oui mais t'inquiète
ouire non mais il faut
l'aider
c'est fr c'est très bien la loi la loi
pas de bon sens c'est la loi ce monsieur
sanstion vous avez quel âge 70 70 ans 70
ans tu veux qu'il rentre dans des
procédures il est
maladeéureit de méctionement il y a
quelque chose qui va pas si un médecin
dit bon vous pouvez vous en passer
pendant quelques semaines et puis vous
allez revenir et puis on verra si plus
tard il faut reprendre l'usage de ce
médicament très bien mais là c'est pas
le cas là c'est la sécurité sociale qui
lui dit sur l'Hôtel De La du coût bah
non monsieur on vous rembourse pas 60 %
du coût de ce médicament moi c'est
quelque chose qui me heurte ça que ce
soit la sécurité sociale qui le dise je
Jean-Pierre alors aujourd'hui vous
voulez quoi qu'est-ce que vous voudriez
vous voudriez être reconnu en fait ben
je voudrais avoir mon médicament au
moins déjà une explication qu'on me dise
pourquoi tout d'un coup paf ça tombe
comme ça quelle loi qui a été voté ou je
ne sais pas
quelle les gens qui nous gouvernent sont
irresponsables ou j'en sais rien mais
voilà ce que je veux c'est être reconnu
que ça serve bien pour moi mais je pense
que je suis pas tout seul dans le cas
merci je pense qu'en France il doit y
avoir du monde merci Jean-Pierre en tout
cas d'avoir été avec nous on espère que
ça va faire bouger les choses pour vous
merciah moi je voudrais bien mais le
député
lui-même enfin pour le moment il a fait
ce qu'il pouvait il a envoyé une lettre
au Premier ministre au ministre de la
santé
mais pas de réponse ça fait plus d'un
mois ça va bientôt faire de moi aucune
réponse incroyable merci Jean-Pierre en
tout cas on va suivre ça aussi de notre
côté merci beaucoup ah ouais